my uh next guest from his year is on
full house and america's funniest home
videos starting next week can be seen in
the new off-broadway play privilege
please welcome bob saget
[Applause]
hello
can i say something and i mean this yeah
very very exciting to see me and i'm not
saying this just because you're here
there's a lot of love for saggett yeah
what is that no i'm it's a good thing i
announced you up front the place went
went wild well i have made love with
half the room yeah i won't say which
half because the others will be hurt
yeah exactly or relieved
[Laughter]
now uh
let's move on um
i had a weird thing today it just
happened 90 minutes ago what's that uh
my my daughter i have three daughters
they're coming uh dj steph and michelle
no i have not
i have three daughters you've clearly
lost your mind
i live in a television set
we have a good life it's real full house
was real yeah and no i have uh three
daughters that are coming here next week
because i'm doing the show here and my
15 year old just left me a voicemail and
this was the voicemail hi dad uh we
can't come next week which is that my
heart dropped hi i'm pregnant
april fools
oh my god and i said you don't lie to me
you need to get pregnant before you come
here
do not lie to your dad that is not a
funny joke that's not funny that's not a
funny april fool's for a dad to hear
yeah
dad did not like that how quickly did
the april fools come i hope it came very
quickly no that's the worst part no i'm
pregnant dad
oh my god i deleted it
you know because that gives you time to
shoot yourself before you hear the april
fools
wow i hope i don't hear that for many
many years yeah from anyone really yeah
really well
but i i'm happy to be here it's good to
see you you're good to see you you're
always looking do i look really good
better even
and you're much taller than people don't
know and you are a tall man noah's
celebrities are tall back me up on this
yeah saggett and i and jeff goldblum are
the only tall
celebrities and then everyone else you
can stand on your hand while you talk to
them they're coming off these shows i'm
like hi welcome to the show hi
there they're tiny little lilliputian
people exactly yeah exactly i like
little people though yes because i can
put them on my hand and keep them in my
drawer yeah yeah that's very strange you
you think full house is real and there's
tiny people living in your drawer what's
interesting is i i uh both john stamos
and dave collier
and the olsen twins all live in new york
city well no but we we uh john and dave
are coming here to see me do the show
next week right but uh we hang out we
live uh with the olsens we had the their
houses recreated to look like full house
yeah that was weird about that show that
was three straight guys raising three
girls in san francisco i don't think
that's even a possibility yeah
but i i i we all say it was a fantasy
yeah it was a perfect world here's a
question i have for you yes sir uh like
two weeks ago i'm out with uh my
producer we went out to get a bite yes
and we run into you and and john stamos
hanging out together you were leaving a
restaurant as we were going in you were
both really wasted and um
and they were coming out of an arby's
which is strange uh
i got i got horsey sauce to go yeah oh
that's it well that's a difference so i
uh so anyway we i i was thinking
afterwards that must be strange when
people see you two
together yeah because you're on this
show together do you know what i mean
well it's weird is i don't think most
sitcom people don't hang out when it's
over it's like eight years and you're
like like conrad bane and gary coleman i
don't think they party yeah right or
screech and tiffany amber thiessen i
don't know they party they party hard
yeah
but uh john and i we we'll go like into
a men's room and uh that's because
that's what we do no we go into a
measurement because we're in love yeah
but uh there'll be like a young 17 year
old kid in there and he'll be like going
to the bathroom and i'll go jesse how's
it going you know is michelle doing okay
i don't know danny i got problems and dj
didn't come back and the kid the kid
just like messes himself up he doesn't
know it he's like oh my god full house
is real
you should bring a little laugh track
with you too in your jacket i do really
mess with people i always hear it yeah
but um now let me ask you about
something uh you did a cameo in a movie
called half baked yeah and
yeah
i could i could tell i could tell this
was a half-baked uh audience
something in the air call it and uh but
but that that became it was just a small
part and a lot of times when an actor
does a you know a quick cameo in a movie
they never really hear about it again
right this movie became this incredible
cult hit yes sir and your cameo has in
some ways become more famous than your
other tv work it's upsetting it's
upsetting and uh
why don't you discuss your cameo for a
second let me tell you kids at home
follow um what happened was i was
directing a movie called dirty work nor
mcdonald movie right that's
that by the way
that is how many people saw it right but
i invited all the people that saw it
here yeah it's a very funny movie so i i
then dave chappelle who's incredibly
funny says uh they asked what i do say
we had the same producer as a half-baked
they said would you do a cameo i read
the script i said sure i'll say that in
a movie that'll be good for me right you
know my parents will be proud my kids
will be happy so i'll just uh i'll say
it as cleanly as i can it's a family
show
worry not
it's a drug rehab scene so it opens well
and dave chappelle comes out and goes
i'm hooked on marijuana and my character
stands up and i go marijuana's not a
drug
i used to suck
blank for coke that's what i said and
you ever suck some blank for marijuana
and he goes no and i go i didn't think
so and that's all i did that except
there was a funny thing a guy goes i
seen him that's like the funniest thing
that's funnier than the movie right
right so so
the problem i have is people yell stuff
at me all the time like you know some
videos you know who wrote your jokes
like i don't know your mom you know but
yeah
i'll be walking with my my real
daughters and uh and a van of 16 year
old guys will go by and they'll go sag
it you rock you suck blank for coke and
i have like my children oh you're a
witch
[Applause]
and like oh
man it ain't right wow and then my my
my uh my my 12 year old's like i thought
you were acting
[Music]
that's what i do honey i'm here
then you're like april fool
it's not april dad i know i have a
problem
so it's it's a nice thing though that
people laugh but uh you know yeah it's
filthy i mean yeah yeah i do stand up
still because i and i'm a little bit
it's not full house you know right right
yeah you're a filthy filthy man in real
life
i don't think people know that about you
but they should
you